he is part of the big slick celebrity
weekend in Kansas City if you are in
Kansas City on June 1st or 2nd please go
there and be a part of it or if not be
part of big slick kc.org to make a
donation cuz all the funds that big
slick collects goes to Children's Mercy
Hospital one of the top pediatric
medical centers in the United States of
America David Koechner here on the show
good to see on the Rich Eisen chil-su
are the highlights of my week
if I get out if I get an icing in there
yes it is so just to mention real quick
people can have a chance you can you
know a chance to come participate in the
big slick weekend with us by donating to
big slick KC org will fly you I for 10
dollars will fly you out put you up and
you get a hangout with all the
celebrities and this year we've got 41
more anyone ever had let's drop some
names you it's it's the usual you Rob
Riggle Paul Rudd Jason Sudeikis and Eric
Stonestreet cuz you're all Kansas
Citians is that the that's the proper
word yeah not Kansas City are they're
all they're all from Kansas I'm the one
from Missouri okay
Kansas City Missouri is larger than
Kansas City Kansas your shows mostly
about geography right yes yeah okay by
the way you know that okay thank you oh
you were just trying to determine what
the show is about I thought you were
gonna go somewhere more with your
geography lesson I'll stay with it I
make my kids learn all the mountain
ranges near our house cuz I'm like we're
you you look out and see mountains you
must know the mountain ranges so I
quizzed them often about that see my
promise I grew up in Staten Island the
mountain that was right outside my house
is made of trash it was made of garbage
world's largest landfill hey growing up
there but I'm damn proud of it cuz right
now it's gonna be turned into a ski
slope cuz that thing's closed and it's
gonna be a great spot you're kidding no
that's what they're gonna do with yes
that's what I've been told
that's from Orica breaking Staten Island
news to David Koechner here on the rich
Iseman well and it has to do with
geography so I'm very happy so did you
guys all know each other like as friends
like back in the day before you hit it
yes now here's the interesting thing
Riggle went to high school with my wife
so he knew my wife before I did
he had briefly dated my wife's younger
sister they were in the same grade he
was a couple years younger than my wife
I'm
Paul of course on anchorman 1 I'd met
Jason Sudeikis when he did the
ImprovOlympic
in Chicago and Stonestreet did the IO in
Chicago and LA so yes I known all of
them prior to the big slick but Riggle
code wriggles the one with the the go
way back yes yes the first time I met
Riggle was in New York before he'd
gotten Saturday Night Live we'd had
dinner a bunch of us and so that's the
five of you speaking of Saturday Night
Live taran killam and Will Forte Forte
comes almost every year right yeah
Charlie Day Adam Devine Al Roker Jolla
true leo is a favorite he was our replay
guy of our Funny or Die video that we
did back in January Jake Tapper for a
little gravitas yeah a little exit a
little sprinkle of gravity this thing's
real yeah Chris Daughtry a Martin Starr
man Chris Harrison who was gonna be
coming on this show shortly that's
amazing and then we're coming we're
doing our show from Kauffman Stadium the
Friday of the event that's that's coming
that's amazing we're doing our C
Brockman you are aware that rise in
inside Robin Dell together well these
guys are coming to the show charity just
got bigger but this is really great for
me
not only because of the obvious of
hanging with you you're being part of a
parcel of a great event
but Brockman is not coming as my plus
one
he is the plus one of the lovely and
talented miss Sarah Tiana who does a
broad a podcast with Bob Riggle with
bathroom with Bob Greco yeah
you don't call him Bob do you I do cuz
nobody else does do we just discover
something I don't know if he even likes
it so I assumed that he would say Hector
funny twice now it's an insult nothing
so it's gonna be like Brockman I've
known you for damn near ten years now
correct right and so you've been
coattail writing for a long time and a
plus one
yeah for me yep for damn near decade
it's gonna be awkward like I don't know
how I'm going to handle it there's gonna
be someone else's plus-one whatever
level of awkward it is I hope to
increase it by ten
gotta love awkward I mean all weekend I
might keep saying so who are you here
with and why are you here oh that's
awkward for him yeah yeah he's not she's
awesome we love her she's just in the
latest photo video who was with with Tim
Simons I'm getting the whole guy
check it out advertising I'm very happy
for both of you how long has it been now
oh I don't know a couple years now
why did you just drop down why'd you go
why don't you go you know I don't
measure things in time and years and
months you make it measure it in
geography exam mountain ranges not like
everyone else there you go okay and she
choose your mountain she's your rock she
is a range a range well I didn't know
what is happening is we're talking about
your girls are the most interesting
fascinating thing about you the improv
comedy club in Tampa May 18th through
20th Memorial Day weekend you will be in
Kansas City Kansas huh not Missouri no
it's in Missouri it is okay for the KC
improv okay for the KC improv which is
in Missouri that's because you're the
real you're from Missouri yeah my wife's
from Kansas City Kansas but I'm from
Missouri all right the Gotham comedy
club in the great city of New York City
on a June 8th the 9th the 15th through
the 17th and Columbus Ohio or on every
day and the mahalia MIDI Club in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania the city of
Champions is is be unknown during the
Cynthia of symphony of chaos Comedy Tour
because that's what my house is a
symphony of chaos they get the five kids
and three dogs how do you do wow dude
last night we had to put on a new pool
cover and Audrey is running for
commissioner of spirits so we're and Eve
needed help with her homework she
doesn't really need the help but she
loves it that's a reason to get a parent
there mm-hmm
I mean it was one of those nights and
then I had to go do stand-up I'm just
like what it was happening so we got to
do Audrey's poster campaign posters just
put that pool cover on with Charlie and
then Eve wants to help see it what was
Audrey's campaign slogan I was I was not
chosen it was everything is okay with a
K or something like Audrey Koechner
and you've got she's got spirit so my
wife and her did most of it I I created
like ten slogan which one did you want I
wanted
hey Bulldogs it's your birthday
with Audrey Koechner it's okay because
that's one of their big jobs as
announcing the birthdays yeah okay
that's part of that's part of what her
would be yes that would be part of her
disease yes part of her duties is
recognizing birthdays of the week huh so
okay so the st. Francis to sale Bulldogs
if you're watching this you shouldn't be
because you're in school excuse me this
is part of this is part of the
curriculum I tell you it we already know
it's educational
you get statistics geography geography
that we're halfway home to the SATs so
what's sick a break coming back in 60
seconds we were talking about retired
numbers by team are you aware your
Kansas City Chiefs have the most retired
numbers in the American football
commenting anything if there is lead the
league in 14 retired numbers yes it's
the ring of fame in the arrowhead it's
but this is just this is not ring a fan
this is retired numbers I understand
we'll see it how many you can guess who
okay okay and then now Mike Dell to fo
you have not heard this yani Laurel
thing right not yeah and you haven't
heard not even even know what it was I I
just saw Stephen King had posted
something on Twitter that said Yanni I'm
like why is he listening to Yanni even
King's a weird guy Dave Stephen King is
brilliant Maine from Maine oh and that's
where you're from sort of sort of I
don't understand why you slugging on
your home state I'm not I'm saying
Maine's amazing okay but he's amazed
amazed a weird is like a is a positive
is that we were saying have you ever
read one of his books rich oh it's
amazing
have you ever listened to writing the
book he wrote about writing where he
narrates it it's just brilliant it's so
fun I never heard of that now I got to
do that you do well anyway when we come
back you at home are you at work or in
the car if you haven't done this Yanni
Laurel thing we're gonna do that live
next in 60 seconds on the rich
very exciting this check on our poll
question is brought to you by Farmers
Insurance the road ahead is bound to
take some unexpected turns farmers
insurance can help you understand your
coverage options with our practical
knowledge gained from more than 90 years
of experience we know what finger to
because we have seen a thing or to find
an agent of farmers calm what do you
have over there Chris broad yeah how
many games does the Eastern Conference
Finals go did you ever answer this rich
go ahead and give the it's four five six
or seven four five six are you into the
hoops thing or not really uh casually
could you just described it you know
like all holy heck breaking loose in the
character household I don't know how
much time you have well there's always
on somewhere okay it's the finals no
it's the Eastern Conference between the
Celtics and the Celtics dropped to
nothing on the Cavs right well there's
seven games how many do you think it
will last how many so we're talking
about the Cavaliers and the Celtics yes
I think it's gonna go all seven because
you're not yeah I think it's gonna go
well seven that wouldn't be a bad choice
all seven 26% yeah five games that leads
the way 33 percent I don't think I don't
think the Celtics take one in Cleveland
this time around they might take a game
six to wrap it up let me tell you what
this babies over if I worth it for you
know I I would not be surprised if the
Cavs suddenly wake up and force a game a
pivotal Game five as you know game fives
David are either decisive where teams up
3-1 and can end it or they're pivotal
game fives where both teams come it to a
piece right you know that's just for you
in case there's an anchorman three you
can work that in there maybe in 10 years
Adam McKay is said so so serious by the
2013 that's what he'd said not a mess
with me he said it in one interview when
he was doing interviews for the Big
Short where he won an Academy Award I
think he was just tired of being asked
the question he said yes but it's gonna
be ten more years cuz that's how long it
took so you mean it
you didn't mean I don't know did it just
I think it's always in the ether what
would it be though as older people I
think we're either going to be in an
underwater city under the ocean or we're
going
to the moon I would take that uh-huh I
take that to the bank man I would see it
you guys could do anything on that front
all four of you and it's it's over I'm
in it's pretty fun yeah okay so it's not
gonna happen is what you're saying I
think it will okay say yes
David Koechner says it's going all right
fire emoji tweet breaking news breaking
news right there okay so the Kansas City
Chiefs have ten retired numbers would
you believe the Oakland Los Angeles
Raiders have zero retired I do believe
that maybe none of them worth it are
she'll hold on a second
the Dallas Cowboys zero retired numbers
is it just a principle thing that I
don't know so it's unbelievable zero
retired numbers for both of those teams
the Bengals have won
oh no well don't start you just go we
can Bengals have one wait who Boomer Bob
Johnson number 54 in your program number
one in your heart what Bob Johnson I
mean linebacker by the way 54 sounds
like it like a linebacker yeah honestly
I know I might be buying my knowledge at
all well god bless the Bob Johnson
family oh and Jake how many how many you
think the Steelers would have retired oh
I guess you'd think 50 but I'm gonna say
10 because you saying the Chiefs have 13
it's high
- Ernie Staunton ER and Joe green that's
it Joe green I get you a green one but
but but I mean for the Super Bowls you'd
think yeah that's it Bob Johnson is what
are you playing needs a center there you
go Center ever you want to take a stab
at the Kansas City Chiefs there's 10 of
them there's some of my I haven't heard
of to be honest with okay well the Len
Dawson has got to be warheads correct
buck Buchanan that is correct now was
he's 75 he's 86 86 right yeah Willie
Lanier
that's correct number 63 yes all right I
had a poster of Willie linear or when I
was in in grade school I mean Willie
linear it's a man I love that they'd
have you know
Simon's poster number 63 and yell
program okay um I'll give you some hints
of the numbers okay number 78 Oh nope
Bobby Bell Oh of course I've been that
Bobby Bell less you're more contemporary
number 58 Oh sack mr. Becker yes Thomas
then there's number 36 Mackley Hill Wow
number 33 Stone Johnson great name a lot
of Johnson's number 28 yes sort of sort
of like Blazing Saddles
yeah number 28 Abner Hanes number 18
Emmitt Thomas Emmitt Thomas an Elmo
right that was the era okay go ahead and
the number 16 Len Dawson and then number
3 Pro Football Hall of Famer Yan Stan
Road correct okay then wide right long
history wide right against the Miami
Dolphins Christmas Day by the way in my
grandmother's house I'm 10 years old
all right yeah we can work it out if you
want okay number three will never be
worn again by a Kansas City chief kicker
all right let's get to this thing right
now oh by the way it's being a big slick
best punter in the NFL will be there too
ultimate Colquitt Colquitt we'll be
there old deuce number two maybe we'll
retire that one by the way that's a
that's an unfortunate nickname deuce
number two little deuce coupe okay it
can be endearing you've redeemed it sure
of course that was a quick kick saving a
beauty right there of course all right
so the whole country is going nuts with
old Twitter versus somebody created a it
sounds like a computer-generated voice
does it yes I've been hurt okay so it
sounds like it and and all human beings
do to some wavelength or frequency or
whatever are hearing this as either the
name Laurel or the name Yanni and I've
heard it both ways which is freaking me
out
Sam I heard it all I heard was Yanni and
everybody who's saying I hear Laurel I'm
like what is your malfunction and then
this morning I put it on this computer
here and all I heard was Laurel and now
I'm freaked out by that dress from a
couple years ago okay exactly what color
is it all right Mike tell Tufo do you
addresses right so every wherever you
are stop what you're doing and go for it
yeah Danny Larry Larry I'm hearing it as
Laurel I'm hearing yanny I'm hearing
Yeti yeah how is this what I heard of
Laurel and then I heard a Yanni I heard
both what in there yeah Annie the whole
time I heard Laurel the whole time
this is do it again did he freaking me
out it again go for it Mike Laurel
Laurel Laurel same um here is yellow no
way any oral now Laurel yeah and I heard
it is Laurel every single time I heard a
Laurel na Yanni yeah all of Harry's yeah
I'm trying to hear Laurel Laurel this is
freaking me out Laurel
alright thank you very much the whole
first time I heard Yanni and the second
time I heard Laurel never heard Laurel
Larry yeah that's all I'm hearing is
Laurel and I was wearing to you what is
happening I heard both the first time
well you're a prism I mean I'm pretty
weird anyway I mean that's a bicameral
mind like our government legislation yes
they're not doing their job oh my gosh
great to see you sir again at david
koechner on twitter where are we gonna
see you next on a big screen or a small
screen there's a independent picture
called Bernard and Huey dropping or on
demand June 8th Bernard and Huey okay so
look for your platforms and then it's
gonna be in select theaters on June 10th
very good I look for and then big slick
kc.org to make a donation and have a
chance to join all of us out there
whoever wins the contest will they be
able to sit next to Brockman on the Rich
Eisen show that's it there you go
yes we're gonna be there on Friday right
and while we're in Kauffman Stadium is
there is a celebrity softball game prior
to the A's and the Royals playing that
night and then the next day there's a
bowling extravaganza and then that the
the ultimate is the Saturday night
affair and the
beautiful what what it's called the the
Arvest bank theater at the Midland
Midland yes yes and you're good that's
been around since like Art Deco days
yeah it's beautiful it's all a marked
it's a beautiful landmark theater where
there's all sorts of performances on
stage and an open bar for all of us
yeah it's a it's a fun fun Jason
Sudeikis his uncle George Wendt is there
right I mean it's it's unbelievable
it's like norm so pumped all right so
I'm not sure if the plus one carries
over to the Midland oh I don't know what
the Midland means it's the it's the big
no it's the big thing that everybody
wants to go to well it's more exclusive
do you have a plus-one Dave yeah my
wife's coming anyway increase the size
of this studio and gentlemen David
Koechner check him out on on Twitter
everybody thanks for coming on the show
thank you always a pleasure you got it
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience